this Net Zero plan is not actually about
saving the climate or avoiding the world
from being destroyed it is a political
decision that is used to crack down on
people's freedom and people's rights
that's what I think Net Zero is exam
again same same mechanism as with covid
but Net Zero is a more efficient one
basically because it affects all of us
if you have an entire population that is
led to believe that our world will be
destroyed within uh you know Greta
tunberg in 2018 said that we would
already be probably wiped off the face
of the earth now
but if you get especially the youth to
believe that and if you get people
afraid then of course you're going to be
able to implement all of these rules
that will restrict our personal freedoms